[Music]  i need to exchange some books  come on well girl you'll need a jane  austen  a virginia wolf and an agatha christie  for reading  your talents are needed somebody stole  from us  we need that money  a change of back they kidnapped an  eight-year-old girl  i can't leave her to die oh you know the  truth give the killed order  [Music]  some bad men are coming to hurt us we  have to go where it's safe  okay  and i teach you to always guard your  back hi mom  am i a grandmother god no  where have you been for the last 15  years around  making sure you're safe  i'm gonna do terrible things to you  girls  we're gonna bring the sky down on the  heads  if i get out of this alive  i'm coming for you goddammit  i'm gonna make a little noise  remember who you're dealing with  you're bleeding it's just a scratch you  can get infected  so get in there and lay eggs and then  they'll have to cut your arm off  that's what they teach you in school  these days  [Music]  you